[Musique]
laquelle
merci merci beaucoup
quelle émotion c'est soir j'ai très
envie de remercier la vie même dans mes
rêves les plus fous je n'aimais sari
jamais imaginé ici à paris recevoir un
césar d'honneur de l'académie du cinéma
français je ne vais pas m'interroger sur
le bien fondé des cèdres et
connaissances
je vais me contenter de me réjouir de
tout mon coeur et d'évoquer quelques
personnes essentielles la france est
toujours été très généreux avec moi
vous m'avez fait sentir chez moi dans
votre cinéma dès lors que j'ai tourné
dans une version du don juan de molière
il y a plus de 20 ans mais son tir
amédée vous me rend très heureuse pour
les passionnés de culture
la france est un pays et spécialement
les sources et les artistes que la
phrase nous ça donnait occuper une place
très privilégiée dans l'histoire et dans
nos vies l'amour de la culture et de la
liberté qui anime les français nous
servir ma chérie marion j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration et d'affection pour toi et
merci beaucoup d'être et et ma côté et
ce soir je t'aime
mais pedro almodovar et mon cher pedro
almodovar je dois parler l'espagnol dame
betty paix c'est moi je sais que tu es
la raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de
faire du cinéma
parce que ton talent dont une menace
inspiration honte allumé et cette flamme
en moi et m'ont donné
l'audace d'y aller et j'ai très
important dans ma vie et merci de
l'hommage que tu rends aux femmes avec
ton cinéma et merci de me lasser
participé à l'agrément et puisqu'on
parle de femmes rurales des ma mère
hélène kengo a allègrement mais mon
équipe en ce sens l'arrivée de noël mon
mentor te remercie pour tout ce que tu
as fait pour notre famille
parce que tu t'es battu pour la paix
nous permet quoi merci des sciences en
moi quand je t'ai dit que je voulais
faire du cinéma et de ne pas m'envoyer
que j'étais complètement folle guerre
n'est pas lé merci maman et merci à mon
père là où tu es tout mon ami frère et
soeur et mon mari mes côtés
blessé pour l'instant g d'essayer de
comprendre que il s'est moqué de l'écart
et j'ai une famille je veux dédier se
servant de famille à mes deux enfants
pour une raison spéciale à la vie sains
sous franco merci à tous